[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend ihnen
allen an diesem Freitag katja hat später
interessante Neuigkeiten zur
Fußballnationalmannschaft ja der
Bundestrainer hat seinen Kader bekannt
gegeben guten Abend unsere Themen heute
abend Friedens noobelpreis für nages
Mohammadi die iranische
Menschenrechtlerin sitzt im Gefängnis
weil sie dem Mull regim unermüdlich die
Stirn
bietet Einigung mit Haken die EU
verständigt sich auf neue asylregeln nur
Polen und Ungarn sträuben sich
weiter die Rückkehr des matzhummels nach
2 Jahren ist der 34-Jährige zurück in
der Nationalelf und soll als Anführer
für neuen Schwung
sorgen in hochangespannter Weltlage gab
es über 350 Nominierungen für den
Friedensnobelpreis hoch gewettet wurde
auf volodomir selenski aber die wohl
wichtigste politische Ehrung der Welt
geht an die iranische Frauenrechtlerin
nagis Mohammadi Glückwünsche aus aller
Welt unter anderem auch vom
Bundeskanzler seit Jahrzehnten kämpft
die 51jährige für die Rechte der Frauen
in Iran ein Dorn im Auge des Muller
Regimes dass die studierte Ingenieurin
immer wieder inhaftieren ließ und sie
derzeit in diesem Gefängnis fesalten
lässt aber ihre Stimme wird trotz gehört
vor allem von den vielen Protestierenden
Frauen die seit dem gewaltsamen Tod der
jungen Kurdin Massa Amini vor einem Jahr
die iranische Führung herausfordern
golinien freed Frau Leben Freiheit mit
diesen Worten verkündet das Nobelkomitee
seine Wahl sie fällt auf narges
Mohammadi seit fast 30 Jahren Aktivistin
für einen friedlichen Wandel und
Frauenrechte in
durch Bildung Fürsprache und zivilen
Ungehorsam zu insgesamt 31 Jahren
Gefängnis wurde sie dafür verurteilt
seit Jahren ist sie getrennt von ihren
Kindern getrennt von ihrem Mann ihre
Familie lebt im Pariser
Exil dieser Preis ist ein Preis für den
Widerstand den Widerstand im ganzen Land
den Widerstand im Gefängnis damit der
Widerstand einer Frau nebenelen anderen
Frauen Essen
wird selbst im Gefängnis organisiert
Mohammadi Proteste enthüllt in ihren
Briefen die sexuelle Gewalt gegen
weibliche Häftlinge selbst dort klärt
sie Frauen über ihre Rechte auf
Augenzeugen berichten wie sie dafür
Schläge erduldet sie bleibt kraftvoll
sogar in ihrem letzten Interview vor
Antritt der jüngsten
Strafe ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass
sich die des reg auf seiner eigenen
Schwäche gründet und auf der Stärke der
Menschen meines
Landes DemonstrantInnen die ins Deutsche
Exil flüchten mussten fiebern heute mit
rasal abdahis Mutter saß mit narges
Mohammadi im Gefängnis am Handy aus dem
Iran erzählt sie wie sie vor Freude
gerade Weine die Mitstreiterinnen
kritisieren genauso wie die
Preisträgerin die
Beschwichtigungspolitik westlicher
Länder gegenüber Iran
die Menschen in Iran haben das Regime
vollständig erkannt sie haben mit diesem
System
abgeschlossen Mohammadi lehnte stets ab
mit der Familie ins Ausland zu ziehen
der Kampf für die Freiheit des Iran sagt
sie sei ihr wichtiger als ihre eigene
Freiheit es waren die Themen Flucht und
Migration die wieder einmal einen
eugipfel beherrscht haben diesmal in
Granada im Süden Spaniens es geht um
viel es geht um die EU asylreform eine
offizielle Abstimmung darüber war zwar
nicht geplant aber eine gemeinsame
einstimmige Erklärung zur
Migrationspolitik sollte es geben als
Signal dass die EU trotz allen Streits
handlungsfähig sei aber auch dagegen
stemmten sich Polen und Ungarn und
sprachen von Diktat und Vergewaltigung
aus Granada Ulf
Röller zumindest soll alles schön
klänzen für den Auftritt der EU Chefs
aber einer HT sich nicht an das
Protokoll der ungarische Regierungschef
Orban greift die anderen EU
Regierungschefs persönlich an verweigert
sich der europäischen Solidarität beim
Thema
Asyl deutlich gesagt die EU hat uns
vergewaltigt sie wollen uns einen
Kompromiss aufzwingen den wir ablehnen
das geht nicht so es gibt keine Einigung
Ungarn und Polen können aber wohl am
Ende einen Kompromiss nicht verhindern
denn die Mehrheit der euchefs ist sich
einig vor allem seit Bundeskanzler
Scholz und die italienische
Regierungschefin Meloni ihren Streit
entschärft haben jetzt ist auch möglich
bei einem besonders starken Anstieg der
Migration Flüchtlinge für einen längeren
Zeitraum unter haftähnlichen Bedingungen
festzuhalten ich bin sehr froh dass
jetzt
gerade zuletzt gelungen ist eine
Verständigung in der Frage der
gemeinsamen europäischen asl Politik das
war dringend erforderlich das ist viele
viele Jahre nicht gelungen die EU prüft
jetzt den Einsatz vom Militär gegen
Schlepper dafür will sie Kapazitäten der
laufenden Operation Irini nutzen deren
Hauptauftrag ist es eigentlich ein
Waffenembargo gegen Libyen zu
überwachen ich denke über den Einsatz
dieses Militärs im Mittelmeer nach aber
dafür brauche ich die Zustimmung
tunisiens
tunesi gemeinsames Familienfoto aber
diese Familie ist ziemlich
zerstritten und Ulf Röller hat den
Gipfel in Granada beobachtet Ulf Ungarn
und Polen Mauern in der asylfrage es
herrscht Uneinigkeit darüber wie es
weitergeht warum gibt es diese
Verwirrung ja das stimmt dieses
asyldiskussion innerhalb der EU die sind
wirklich sehr verwirrend und schwer zu
verfolgen das Grundproblem ist dass es
eben diese zwei Länder gibt Polen und
Ungarn die in total Opposition sind die
ganz klar sagen egal wie dieser
Kompromiss aussieht sie werden nicht
mitmachen sie werden keine Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen und sie werden auch keine
Strafen zahlen weil sie keine
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen und natürlich kann
dieser Kompromiss aber nur funktionieren
wenn alle mitmachen in Europa wenn alle
solidarisch sind und deshalb hat der
Bundeskanzler heute sehr deutlich auch
Ungarn kritisiert es hat ja hat gesagt
es kann ja nicht sein dass man nicht
mitmacht und dann uns die Flüchtlinge
aus Ungarn Schi also da gibt es richtig
Knatsch das große Problem ist keiner
weiß wie man Ungarn und Polen dazu
bringen soll die Blockade aufzuh heben
und deshalb besteht diese große
Verwirrung danke für die Einordnung nach
Granada Ulf
rüller die deutsche Außenministerin
Annalena berbock die war heute auf der
westbalkanonferenz in Albanien
eigentlich geht es dort darum die Länder
des westlichen Balkans an die EU
heranzuführen aber auch heute hieß es
wieder krisendiplomatie denn die
Spannungen zwischen Serbien und dem
Kosovo spitzen sich zu zuletzt hieß es
sogar Serbien habe Truppen an der Grenze
zusammengezogen Andreas künerst mit mehr
das gibt Ärger dass die Gastgeber ganz
selbstverständlich die blaugoldene Fahne
des Kosovo zu all den anderen ins Bild
stellen ist für Serbien ein Skandal eine
Stunde hat die deutsche Ministerin
berwock auf den serbischen Minister dic
eingeredet erfolglos dic bleibt sitzen
solange die kosovofahne steht
westbalkkanantreffen tiraner Gruppenbild
20 Staaten minus Serbien 24 Jahre lang
hat der Westen hat die KFOR
Friedenstruppe den serbienkosovo
Konflikt eingedämmt nun bricht er wieder
auf die Lage ist so angespannt wie schon
länger nicht mehr
deshalbtinat K verstärkt hilflos hat K
mit angesehen wie vor wieder Schüsse
fallen wieder Menschen sterben eine
Drohne hat die 30 bewaffneten Serben
gefilmt die im Norden des Kosovo einen
Polizisten erschießen hier verschanzen
sie sich in einem Kloster im
Feuergefecht werden auch drei von ihnen
sterben während Serbiens Außenminister
jede Beteiligung bestreitet verlangt
Kosovo dass die EU Serbien
verurteilt und auch konkrete Schritte
unternommen werden um Serbien dafür zu
sanktionieren ein Nachbar angegriffen zu
haben dass Serbien seine Truppen an der
Grenze verstärkt hat alarmiert den
Westen zusätzlich eigentlich sollen
diese Gipfel Treffen der sogenannte
Berliner Prozess die Staaten des
westlichen Balkans näher an und
irgendwann in die EU führen aber jetzt
muss die EU erstmal nicht weniger
schaffen als einen neuen Krieg zu
verhindern Großbritannien und Rumänien
schicken der kfur nun zusätzliche
Soldaten Deutschland überlegt
noch im Fall krupala hat die zuständige
Staatsanwaltschaft bekannt gegeben dass
nach umfangreichen toxikologischen
Untersuchungen keine auffälligen
Substanzen im Blut des afdchefs gefunden
wurden im Arztbrief des Klinikums ist
die Rede von einem Nadelstich im rechten
Oberarm Tino kopalla war während einer
Wahlkampfveranstaltung in Ingolstadt in
ein Krankenhaus gebracht worden seine
Partei spricht seitdem von einem
tätlichen Übergriff die
Staatsanwaltschaft hat darauf bislang
keine Hinweise
ja vieles ist undurchsichtig und
rätselhaft in dem Fall einiges unklar
und wenn Sie alles noch mal nachlesen
wollen was stand der Dinge ist wir haben
die Fakten zusammengestellt in der ZDF
heute
App an diesem Sonntag wird gleich in
zwei großen Bundesländern gewählt in
Bayern und in
Hessen nach dem aktuellen ZF
Politbarometer würde die CDU in Hessen
32% erreichen Grüne und SPD jeweils 17%
die AFD käme auf 16 die FDP auf 5 die
Linken und die Freien Wähler kämen nicht
in den Landtag in Bayern unangeefochten
an der Spitze die CSU mit
37% die Grünen liegen bei 16 Freie
Wähler 15 AFD 14%. die SPD 9 und die FDP
wäre nicht im Landtag vom Wahlkampf port
in Bayern berichtet jetzt Petra
Neubauer dieser Ring soll Wünsche
erfüllen erklärt der bayerische dem NRW
Ministerpräsidenten der Spaziergang
durch Söders Heimatstadt Nürnberg ein
Dankeschön für die Wahlkampfhilfe
wünschen dürfte sich Söder noch mehr
Rückenwind für seine CSU die weit
entfernt ist von der Stärke früherer
Jahre es geht nicht um einen
Schönheitspreis jetzt es geht um einen
stabilen
rabierungsauftrag für die CSU und auch
für den Ministerpräsidenten das deutet
sich jedenfalls in allen Umfragen und an
der Stimmung der Bevölkerung wieder und
es ist auch ganz besonders wichtig um
ein Land zusammenzuhalten mit Hubert
eiwangers Freien Wählern würde Söder
gerne weiter regieren kein liebes eher
ein Zweckbündnis die flugblattaffäre hat
eiwanger noch gestärkt durch seine
Freien Wähler sei garantiert dass wir
die Themen der Mitte besetzen dass die
Normalbürger wieder eine ansprach in der
politischen Mitte haben und nicht aus
verust komische Parteien wählen müssen
die Grünen werden von der CSU als
Koalitionspartner kategorisch abgelehnt
sie sehen sich aber als unerlässliches
Bollwerk gegen Rechts immer wieder
kommen Menschen zu mir die sagen sie
haben Angst vor einem Rechtsrutsch in
Bayern sie machen sich Sorgen um die
Demokratie und sie wünschen sich eine
starke grüne Stimme im nächsten
Bayerischen Landtag und am besten in der
bayerischen Staatsregierung mit der AFD
will niemand koalieren dennoch hat sie
Pläne fürs Regieren gerade beim Thema
Flucht wir werden das Asylrecht
wiederherstellen pushbacks einrichten
und sachstadt Geldleistungen aus
ausbezahlen und noch eins wir werden
abschieben abschieben ab soziale Themen
im Mittelpunkt bei der SPD die Partei im
Umfragetief hofft auf einen
Stimmenzuwachs im letzten Moment weil es
wichtig wäre für die Menschen in Bayern
dass da jemand da ist der sich für
Mieterinnen und Mieter einsetzt für
bezahlbare Wohnungen für gute Kitas die
kostenfrei sind für die älteren Menschen
die FDP muss zittern und bietet alles
auf um noch Boden gut zu machen brauch
eine FDP im Bayerischen Landtag als eine
starke Stimme Bürgerrechte eine starke
Stimme für die Marktwirtschaft eine
Stimme für die individuelle Freiheit und
das würde ohne die FDP fehlen rund 9,4
Millionen Menschen sind in Bayern
stimmberechtigt bis Sonntag 18 Uhr haben
Sie die
Wahl jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine die
UNO will Ermittler in das Dorf Rossa
schicken dort waren gestern etwa 50
Menschen getötet worden zurzeit deute
alles auf einen russischen
Raketenangriff hin sagte ein unosprecher
auch heute gab es wieder Luftangriffe in
hakif haben Raketen ein Wohngebiet
getroffen ein 10 Jahre altes Kind und
seine Großmutter wurden tot aus den
Trümmern geborgen nach ukrainischen
Angaben gab es außerdem 30
Verletzte eine andere permanente Gefahr
für die Menschen in der Ukraine sind die
Minen das Innenministerium schätzt 30%
des ukrainischen Staatsgebiets müsse
entmient werden extrem gefährliche
Arbeit für die räumungsdienste die sich
meine Kollegin Anne Brühl anschauen
Stopp Minen war das Schild am Fahrzeug
wir sind unterwegs mit einer
Spezialeinheit des staatlichen
Rettungsdienst der Ukraine Schutzweste
Helm ohne die geht es für die Männer
nicht die Russen haben hier
Antipersonenminen
abgeworfen bis wir das nicht gemacht
haben bleiben Leute von der Zivilisation
abgeschnitten
Maschine Räumen die Männer den Bereich
unter einer zerstörten Stromleitung wir
sind in der Region hakiv die russische
Grenze ist nur 10 Kilom entfernt ein
halbes Jahr lang hatten die Russen das
Gebiet besetzt erst langsam trauen sich
die Bewohner zurück ins
Dorf wir hatten Angst weil viele
Menschen durch Minen betroffen sind ums
Leben gekommen sind unser Nachbar in der
anderen Straße hat sein Bein verloren
wir konnten nicht früher
kommen geschätzt müssen 30% des
ukrainischen Staatsgebiets entmient
werden es ist eine Mammutaufgabe selbst
in diesem Dorf in dem es nur ein paar
hundert kleine Häuser
gibt es wird Jahre dauern um diese
Siedlung zu entmienen Jahre das war ein
Kampfgebiet und Gott weiß was sich hier
alles
befindet schon jetzt sagen die Ukrainer
sei ihr Land das größte Minenfeld der
Welt
sie kommen in Gruppen stehen was zu
greifen ist und schrecken auch vor der
Anwendung von Gewalt nicht zurück
Geschäfte in den USA erleben ein noch
nie daagewesenes Niveau an
bandendiebstellen oft schützen dann auch
teure Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nicht mehr
immer mehr Läden kapitulieren müssen
dicht machen Heike slanski
berichtet diese Bilder von hemmungslosen
Raubzügen sind aus Philadelphia ganze
Horden von teils noch nicht einmal
vermummten stürmen zahlreiche
Konsumtempel die Polizei ist zur Stelle
kann jedoch nur einen kleinen Teil der
Verbrecher
schnappen das ist kein Ladendiebstahl
sondern Plünderung
Aufruhr teils am helligen Tag im ganzen
Land diese Vorfälle Diebstahl in Gruppen
brutale Zerstörung häufig wird die Beute
anschließend im Internet verschärbelt
die Täter scheuen vor keinem Produkt
zurück sogar ein Nagelstudio zertrümmert
die Eigentümerin
verzweifelt ich arbeite Tag und Nacht 6
S Tage die Woche habe mir das hier alles
mühsam aufgebaut und dann passiert das
hier immer mehr Händler geben auf die
landesweit erfolgreiche Ladenkette
namens target hat bereits neun Filialen
geschlossen viele Produkte ob Zahnpasta
oder Rasierschaum weggeschlossen in
Vitrinen in Oakland nah San Francisco
protestieren Geschäftsleute fühlen sich
vom Staat im Stich
gelassen wenn die Verbrecher nach der
Festnahme wieder auf freiem Fuß sind
führt das nicht zu mehr
Sicherheit kollektive Plünderungen
unzureichende
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen eine zunehmende
Verrohung die immer mehr US-Bürger
verunsichert jetzt zum Sport und zur
ersten offiziellen Amtshandlung des
neuen Fußball buundestrainers Katja ja
es wurde der Kader für die kommende
Länderspielreise in den USA gesucht und
Julian nagelsmann hat nominiert drei
Neulinge sitzen am Montag im Flieger und
Matz summels ist nach zweijähriger
Zwangspause zurück in der National 11
Matz Hummels Dortmunds Abwehrchef soll
die Defensive der dfb1 wieder
stabilisieren Bundestrainer nagelsmann
sieht ihn auch in der Führungsrolle ja
Matz ist ein Spieler mit einer sehr
großen Erfahrung und das auch das was
wir sehen wollen hat natürlich
exzellenten Spielaufbau er hat immer den
Mut auch bin Mittelfeld zu spielen einer
von drei neuen Mittelfeldspieler Robert
Andrich von Bayer Leverkusen Premiere
auch für den offensivstarken Stuttgarter
Chris fürüich überraschend die
Nominierung des kopfballstarken Stürmers
Kevin berensz von Union Berlin wir
müssen versuchen durch eine Art und
Weise durch Art und Weise wir spielen
wollen durch ein aktiven Fußball eine
Stimmung innerhalb der Mannschaft zu
erzeugen die ja jeden mit GI und Lust
auch bei der Nationalmannschaft spielen
lässt auch dabei Thomas Müll einer von
fünf vom FC Bayern der nicht nur für
gute Stimmung sorgen
soll schlecht gespielt trotzdem gewonnen
so das knackige Fazit aus Sicht von
Bayern Leverkusen im Europa League Spiel
beim norwegischen dubelsieger Molde
FK auf dem ungewohnten Kunstrasen in
Molde profitiert Leverkusen in Weiß früh
von einem Abwehrfehler Jeremy frmong mit
dem 1:0 in der 14 Minute 4 Minuten
später trifft der englische Neuzugang
Nathan Teller erstmals im Bayer Trikot
ein Jahr nach seinem abtsantritt in
Leverkusen muss Trainer Xavi Alonso aber
noch um seinen 25 Sieg bangen Emil
breiwig erzielt kurzvschluss den
Anschlusstreffer für die Norweger
Leverkusen gewinnt 2:1 und nimmt mit
sechs Punkten aus zwei Spielen Kurs auf
die Korunde ja und im anderen Europa
League Spiel unterlag Freiburg westham
United 1:2 und in der Conference League
verlor Eintracht Frankfurt bei Pauk
Saloni ebenfalls
1:2 Jerome boeng kehrt doch nicht zum FC
Bayern München zurück offizielle
Begründung des Vereins die personelle
Situation in der Innenverteidigung habe
sich entspannt die Rückkehr war
umstritten weil sich Boateng unter
anderem wegen Körperverletzung vor
Gericht verantworten muss und noch dies
Turner lcas Dauser wurde bei der WM in
Antwerpen im mehkampf 16 aber an seinem
Paradegerät dem Barren ertonte er sich
wieder die Höchstnote des Tages mit
15,400 Punkten und kann sich Sonntag im
Einzelfinale an diesem Gerät quasi nur
selber schlagen der Olympia und WM
zweite ist Klara
Favorit und die T WM morgen und
übermorgen von 14 Uhr an im Livestream
in der Mediathek und in der heute App
hab vielen Dank Katja so am Ende dieser
Sendung erfahren Sie noch ein wenig
Erleuchtung die geht von Berlin aus mit
viel Licht und Farbe klar bunt
angestrahlte Gebäude die hat man schon
oft gesehen aber selten mit so viel
Kreativität und Perfektion wie beim
Festival of flights bis Mitte des Monats
schauen staunen an vielen Orten über die
ganze Stadt
verteilt so nach dem Regen wird's wieder
wärmer mehr gleich von östen terli das
heute journal ab 22 Uhr mit Marietta
Slomka wir sagen danke fürs zuschauen
und gerne bis
[Musik]
morgen
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter unser
satellitenfilm von heute zeigt Nebel
schauen Sie hier und der verschwand im
Tagesverlauf man sieht ganz gut wie er
sich allmählich auflöst aber es gibt
auch viele Wolken zu sehen im Norden und
mit diesen Wolken gibt es in der
kommenden Nacht auch Regen und dieser
Regen tririffet allmählich südwärts ganz
im Süden merkt man nichts davon hier
wieder in Gewässernähe Nebel teils klart
es auch verbreitet auf bei tiefsten
Temperaturen im Süden bis 1 Grad hier
also schon richtig kalt 16° im
Nordwesten deutlich milder morgen
driftet der Regen weiter südwärts und
zum Abend erreichte die Mitte vorher ist
es hier aber noch trocken ganz im Süden
viel Sonnenschein mit höchsten Werten
bis 24° im Südwesten hier Schrammen wir
also an einem Sommertag vorbei Kühler im
Norden in Schleswig-Holstein bei 15° die
nächsten Tage weiterhin viel sonnenschin
am Sonntag nach südostenin allerdings
Regen mit vielen Wolken 12 bis 26° und
sie sehen im Nordosten bleibt es
generell kühler als im Südwesten ja und
am Montag bis 27 Dienstag bis
28° schönen Abend